se cercate tra il face quest sull'app
store di escono fuori tono facebook dove
mentre il face quest al lucky che quello
che faremo oggi e poi ci sono altre cose
strane tipo divertente gioco strano che
cazzo vuol dire sorella di pazzo sorella
di per chi è pazzo il mio amico brutto
troll carnevale del cazzo vuol dire tra
il formaggio schioccare giusto non oso
pensare la descrizione c'è scritto fermi
storia del più strano gioco
sì c'è un sì perché rafforza questo è il
tipo di trucco che si vuole colpire il
telefono per giocare per provare
nuovamente ma mantenuto il gioco
naturalmente ci sono molti partner per
tutti i fidanzati siamo poco
intelligente attraverso non stop per
cercare di analizzare e sdoganamento vi
è grande e la provincia ma la poesia di
d'annunzio e la prova di un ragazzo
casual
questo gioco è molto molto difficile c'è
legno lì poi nel cazzo ti amo ragazzi
proviamo ad avviare tra il fisco e syria
primi tron quest unlucky incredibile che
cazzo hai bevuto stamattina al primo
tentativo non è mai successo fantastico
allora ragazzi in questo videogame ci
sono un sacco di livelli che avevo già
fatto negli scorsi trophies quest tipo
così qui di una sensata gene e unica
quindi se capita che salto qualche
livello e per questo motivo qui ok che
se non l'avevo fatto invece cos'è c'è un
gatto tra l'altro ai gatti vanno trovati
tipo le galline nell'altro prefetto devo
alzare la tavoletta del cesso
non ci avevo dubbi che ci sarebbe stato
qualche cristiano nel cesso si sarà
buttato lì dopo aver letto la
descrizione del gioco fino l'acqua e
rafforza e l'unica cosa che viene in
mente a posto è andato a chi è adesso
posso cagare in pace si spera che non
gli vada a finire la merda in testa poi
la madonna ma entra lerby 06 p no io a
prato fiorito ragazzi ho sempre giocato
da pico mai vinto un cazzo nella mia
vita troviamo ho vinto non cazzo mi hai
detto dove sono le mine zio un'acqua
allora sei stronzo devos trascinare
qualcosa sicuro perché interface test
devi trascinare le cose tipo tipo così
[Musica]
quanta intelligenza e una sola persona
dio mio
dopo questa chiudo l'epicità cioè questa
è la scena di matrix pillola rossa
pillola blu bellissimo guarda morpheus
quante nano cazzo io prendo la pillola
rossa e vedo quanto è profonda la tana
delle bianco minchia morpheus mia
crollato che è simpatico allora
prendiamo la pillola blu a castelvenere
non era neanche la pillola blu perfetto
che cazzo derivi devo trascinare
un'altra volta qualcosa sia tanto c'è un
gatto qui che non hanno visto un livello
difficile c'è ragazzi non l'ha se non lo
sto capendo
ok per cento non avevo assolutamente
dubbi i ragazzi anzi tu sei l'eletto e
me lo stai dimostrando adesso sei pronto
ad entrare in matrix
mi spiegate come ci è finito un gatto lì
però avere un importa devo spiegare
questo tronco in testa al tizio sono un
[ __ ] genio bastava spostarsi no
perché secondo te josè cavo il tronco
sud a seguito di fini c'è mai limite
secondo te sono scemo non so c'è scritto
idiota in testa hanno infatti ve lo
giuro su chi volete che non l'ho fatto
apposta
questo riuscito scappata devi spostarti
che ho fatto a spostarmi prima ok e
ritroviamo argomento dell'idiota questo
questo volevo dall'inizio roldos mi
scusi lei non si fa non si depila al
braccio da un po di tempo vada a casa
come devo cambiare dalla madonna
dobbiamo continuare così per quanto ad
andare fino all'orario di chiusura
sicurissimo lo sapevo adesso hai un
motivo di scoraggiare signor sa se ne va
proprio così c'è proprio la scorreggia
reazione fantastica anch'io faccio così
per alzarmi la mattina sono mal sarei
manco per il bene condividi i tuoi
progressi no guarda non ci tengo che i
miei amici sappiano che gioca sta merda
a meno che non guardino questo video
intaccato sono io nella merda che sta
roba
oddio non compiuta non c'è
la madonna also l'enigmista fantastico
cosa faccio devo tagliare i fili cavi
portò a buon punto 6 malvagio cosa
faccio lo spengo il televisore aspetto
bastava spegne giusto anche quelli che
sono morti nel film di so perché non ci
hanno pensato basta a spegnere
televisore
già so cosa devo fare ancora non ho
fatto niente c'è un armadietto più
colorato lo sapevo lo sapevo era più
colorato del resto del livello quindi lo
hanno cliccato subito una chiave
nell'armadietto c'è qualcosa che altro
gli eventi in fallout da che sono stato
un genio a finirlo ancora prima di
perdere e far vedere cosa succedeva se
cliccato giudizio ad uno scatto le
caramelle giusto ma c'erano gli
scarafaggi che le caravelle perché o mio
dio si sta avvicinando qualcosa bastardo
per questa macchina perché la macchina
fase la top ten anche quella dei
flinstones sono arrivato sul gas quindi
passa la bandiera fa qualcosa ragazzoni
fa niente infatti i cazzi tuoi camion
della merda non ci arrivava fino alla
bandiera che ne so io cos'è sta roba ci
sono un miliardo di facce bisogna fare
ad ultimare tutti il troll face 9 sono 9
e non sono dieci cazzo sono 9 e non ce
ne è questo e non ce ne sono dieci ce ne
sono ok mi sono ricordato sotto il credo
di averlo già fatto sto livello non mi
ricordo ma mi pare che se adesso mi
spunta la schermata con la dominici che
ho perso
c'è la faccia del trolley la devo
cliccare credo mi pareva che fosse così
e non vorrei dire ecco infatti
tutto nell'anno questo avevo già fatto
ragazzo me lo ricordavo quindi sicuro
che avevo già provato questo non me lo
ricordo spero di non averlo già fatto
così devi solo lanciare un sasso
wow fantastico la difficoltà dopo zio
cosa fa ma spiegami perchè ci sono dei
sommozzatori in un lago abbandonato
anche da gesù che stai cercando la tua
simpatia perché non l'ho ancora non l'ho
trovata io sistema non farfalla
elettricista oggi facciamo che ti
avvicini poco più chiudilo adesso chiudi
non si deve andare dentro sei mica
deficiente alcune cose mi dovete
spiegare perché ci sono cose che non
capisco
ma cosa cazzo vuol dire cos'è un mio dio
allora qui sarà preso persia mi piace
giocavo io sto penso perso bellissimo
non saltare si cose io ho capito sto
saltare io le cose io mi hanno modo a
far vedere troppo figo tratta per
saltare o io per saltare ragazzi
trascinando in basso spiegatemi come
casa lo fa è arrivato lì voglio prima
muoio qua
l'ultima non si staccava giustamente non
potevo sapere mai però ok trova il face
arcieri pcus estero che faccio schiaccio
i tasti dove arrivare a 100 non ho mai
usato le dita così velocemente nella mia
vita non pensate male 7 98 99
lo sapevo lo sapevo io non sapevo che mi
avrebbe cambiato il tasso davis hucare
tutto
senti l'uomo non so chi tu sia però mi
dai fastidio perché c'è una spada non ha
detto tra l'altro quello è un toro finto
la cerniera spiegami ciao ciao miniero
ci vedeva una cerniera e non sono scemo
assegno da un milione che ho insegnato
alla pirlo consegnare subito questo qui
non segno da milione consegnato ad un
troll face che somiglia ad andrea diprè
cosa facciamo nostro regalo tieni del
supporto degli a casa con quale cura tra
femmine assegni che su file non dovresti
buttatelo dato perché me li devi tenere
o lanciarlo da qualche parte che non sia
lì
tipo tecnico pensavo che tu potessi dare
l'assegno alla banca che la banca
potesse materializzarsi i soldi siamo
quasi a 30 alzate sito i cazzi di mani
perché sei andato al suo concerto se ti
fa cagare zio spiegami non sono più
bravo io del cantante dio mio ego
cliccarli no vabbè geniale dovevo
spegnere volume del gioco va bene questa
è questa la geniale ci siamo ragazzi e
l'ultimo livello questo in teoria solo
che l'avevo già fatto anche questo me lo
ricordo solo che non mi ricordo come non
premere i tasti devo andare no e non mi
ricordo di omino sono passati sei anni
devo già ad un click ha retto è infatti
non ricordavo dopo mandarlo in tilt
adesso mi sono andato su giù sinistra
destra saranno anche nel futuro tico
tico ho vinto tre a è quale siamo
arrivati al piano 13 in questo gioco
completa chi è questo perché perché
piangere si è commosso perché ho
completato il gioco che beh avrei
preferito morpheus che si commuovesse
morpheus quindi raga solis spero che vi
sia piaciuto spero che abbiate imparato
che le descrizioni di giochi sono più
belle dei giochi stessi ma poco tanto
mandatemi limiti screen delle
descrizioni dei giochi strane proprio
che così ci faccio un video su quella
perché fanno troppo scassati delega
spero che video vi sia piaciuto cosa che
mi è piaciuto sono commento mi piace
anche a faccia di facebook e condivido
frana l'iscrizione aspetto gli screen
dei giochi che farò un fido appunto solo
sulle descrizioni dei giochi strani
quindi se trovate dei giochi con dei
nomi strani o con le descrizioni strane
ma andatevene che mi fanno scattare la
genesi di schede lì ci vediamo così ho
visto ragazzi
[Musica]